hey 42 here nowadays it seems that going
viral can happen to anything from Mass
dance alongs to unruly Council meetings
on Zoom but even at a time when
seemingly inconsequential incidents get
there five minutes of fame it takes
something quite special to have been
watched by 20 of the world's population
and yet that's the claim made by sure
leader least secret secret agent of all
time James Bond
ever since his hugely popular blend of
murder and martinis hits the big screen
back in 1962. it's fought that close to
one and a half billion people have seen
a Bond movie at some point in their life
and according to Forbes the film series
has grossed almost 8 billion dollars at
the box office making it the fifth most
lucrative franchise in cinema history
the books on which the Bond films are
based with a work of British author Ian
Fleming and they established an
intoxicating formula of beautiful women
exotic locations and increasingly
unbelievable Global crises
Lieutenant Commander Fleming served as a
naval intelligence officer during the
second world war and like Bond he had a
taste for the Finer Things in life as
well as an unshakable or perhaps I
should say unsturable conviction in his
abilities when it came to sports women
and gambling so it seems entirely
appropriate that it was whilst at the
baccarat tables of the casino esterol in
Lisbon that Fleming first encountered
the man who was to make a lasting
impression on him that man's name was
pop-off dusam Popoff and over the years
many have speculated that he was the
real life inspiration for the character
of James Bond and it isn't hard to see
why popov's life was every bit as
outrageous as the film icon that he
inspired he took unbelievable risks
working as a double agent to thwartz the
Nazis during the second world war
gambled with the kind of money most
people don't make in a lifetime and
course some of the most famous movie
stars of his day he even had a code name
tricycle and whilst that might not sound
all that cool if you think about it it
kind of makes him double O free
now I'd like to take a minute to talk
about hair loss because I've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their 20s and it's always been
an upsetting experience if you're in the
same boat then you're not alone did you
know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you still
got hair left I really like keeps
because it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
straight to your door every three months
so you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits and waiting in Pharmacy checkout
lines there's a reason that keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trust them for their hair loss
prevention medication if you're like me
you're probably not ready to lose your
hair just yet but prevention is key fast
you act of fast you'll see results and
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save
if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com 42 or click
the link in the description to receive
50 off your first order
thanks to keeps for sponsoring this
video
Popoff was born into a wealthy family in
1912 in what is now Serbia but was then
part of Yugoslavia he was expensively
educated and by the time he was a
teenager he was already fluent in French
German and Italian not that he was a
model student by any means he was
expelled from at least one school after
snapping the cane wielded by a teacher
in front of his presumably wildly
cheering classmates
his combination of intelligence bravery
and a desire for Danger made him perfect
spy material and he added political
activism to his long list of enviable
qualities during his time studying law
at the University of Freeburg in Germany
this was the mid-1930s and Nazism was on
the rise
whilst many kept their opinions on the
newly installed fascist government to
themselves
Popov wrote a series of newspaper
articles that openly ridiculed Hitler
and his cronies it's therefore
unsurprising that upon completing his
PhD in 1937 he was arrested by the
Gestapo the Nazis much feared secret
police and thrown in jail luckily
popov's family connections saw to it
that he was only in The Slammer for
eight days his father managed to get the
Yugoslavian prime minister himself to
personally intervene and secure his
son's release
Popoff then moved to Dubrovnik in
Croatia and spent the next few years
practicing law and chasing women
something he needed no practice at
whatsoever
it wasn't all law school and ladies
though there was a small matter of the
second world war starting up and
although the German invasion of
Yugoslavia didn't take place until April
1941. Popov became involved with the war
effort in 1940. through a friend named
Johann Johnny deppson like Popov yepsen
came from a wealthy family he was a son
of a German shipping magnate and the two
had gotten to know each other at
Freeburg University
James bonding not over liking the same
brand of supernoodles as most students
do but because of a shared love of
sports cars but there was more to yebson
than met the eye because it turned out
he'd been recruited by the adver the
German military intelligence service not
that he was a big Nazi sympathizer being
part of the advert simply meant he could
still travel as much as he needed for
his business
on the Proviso that he sent back
information when requested
to begin with Popov wasn't overly
impressed with his friend's new role
passing information to the Nazis but he
soon came to realize that working for
German intelligence was the perfect
opportunity to work against the regime
and so when yebson suggested that Popov
should also become an advert agent he
agreed immediately rather than celebrate
the new job Popov went straight to the
British Embassy in Belgrade to tell them
what had happened and they referred him
to their passport control office which
was in fact a cover for the MI6 agents
who were working there
amongst them Worcester wonderfully named
Clement hope and it was he who enrolled
Popov as a double agent the
International import export business in
which popov's family were involved
proved excellent cover for both his
so-called work for the Germans and his
real work for the British he relocated
to London but made frequent trips to
Lisbon where the advert handlers were
based Portugal played an important role
in the war as it remained officially
neutral throughout the conflict
that along with its key position on the
Atlantic Ocean and as a point of entry
into Spain made it a magnet for spies
from both sides during his time in
Lisbon pop Huff would provide the
Germans with either unimportant or
simply downright false information given
to him by the British and it was here in
August 1941 that he crossed paths with
Ian Fleming at the time Fleming was
working as an assistant to rear Admiral
John Godfrey the director of Naval
intelligence incidentally it's rumored
that Godfrey served as the inspiration
for Fleming's character M the fictional
leader of MI6 they were returning from a
visit to Washington with a stopover in
Lisbon and whilst Godfrey continued back
to London Fleming remained in the
Portuguese capital for several weeks
presumably taking the opportunity to
sample some of those delicious custard
tart thingies whilst also overseeing an
active International Espionage on
you see whilst Fleming was there Popoff
was undertaking an operation codenamed
Midas to steal forty thousand dollars
from adver high up major ludovico Von
karstoff the advert were happy to give
pop off the cash as they believed he was
busy setting up a network of spies in
England and he was using those funds to
pay them in reality he was simply
passing the loot straight to the Allies
Admiral Godfrey had ordered Fleming to
remain in Lisbon to ensure that once
Popoff had the cash he did The Honorable
thing and gave it to the people he'd
actually stolen it for it was no secret
that Popoff was an avid Gambler and with
thirty thousand dollars burning a hole
in his pocket that's about 600 Grand in
today's money the temptation of having a
little flutter must have been enormous
so enormous in fact that after enjoying
a slap up meal in a nice restaurant
pop-off did in fact make a beeline for
the nearest casino with of a nervous in
Fleming following close behind Fleming
was right to be nervous too because
accompanied by gasps from other gamblers
pop off promptly placed the entire sum
in his possession on a single hand of
baccarat to call the bluff of another
Gambler who'd arrogantly insisted on
playing no limits
as it happens the other Gambler was
indeed bluffing because he quickly
backed down and the sun was never
actually wagered but it seems it's
absolutely ball a move planted a seed in
Fleming's mind because a remarkably
similar scene appears in Fleming's debut
Bond novel Casino Royale where our hero
uses MI6 funds to humiliate Soviet agent
Le Schiff taking 80 million francs from
him in a tense game of baccarat popov's
war effort went far beyond funneling
funds to the allies and inspiring future
literary icons directly after making a
big impression in Portugal he was sent
by the advert to America where they
hoped he could set up another aspiring
similar to the one he'd pretended to set
up in the UK
there was also a request from Germany's
new ally Japan who suspiciously wanted
as much information as Popoff could
obtain about the American Naval Base at
Pearl Harbor in Honolulu Hawaii when
Popoff arrived in the U.S he went to the
FBI to explain why he'd been sent and
raised the alarm about a possible attack
on a key military Target
but he struggled to gain an audience
with FBI director J Edgar Hoover who
rumor has it wasn't the biggest fan of
British spies operating in America
Hoover did eventually come down from
Washington to meet Popov but the whole
thing could hardly have gone any worse
as Hoover seemed personally affronted by
popov's decadent Playboy lifestyle it
probably didn't help that Popoff had
rocked up with a glamorous young British
woman and Hoover threatens to have this
by arrested under the man act which
forbade men to transport women across
state lines for any moral purpose as it
happened Popoff wasn't arrested and
however moral or otherwise that
relationship with his traveling
companion might have been it didn't last
long because he soon broke it off to
begin an affair with friends film star
Simone Simon who was in the U.S filming
horror classic cat people nothing like
keeping a low profile when you're a spy
hey
flings with movie stars aside popov's
trip to America wasn't exactly a great
success the advert were annoyed that he
hadn't been given permission to travel
to Hawaii and the British were miffed
that one of their star agents had been
largely ignored
the information pop-off passed to the
FBI was for whatever reason not acted
upon and so on the 7th of December 1941
the Japanese Air Force launched a
devastating attack on Pearl Harbor
whilst in America popov's lifestyle
remained as lavish as ever and British
documents Declassified in 2002 so that
he ran up huge bills spending money on a
luxury car a penthouse on Park Avenue in
New York and skiing holidays in the
mountains of Idaho
what popov's value as an agent was
undeniable and he was soon to make his
greatest contribution yet to the Allies
winning the war as he played a crucial
role in Operation Fortitude the lengthy
campaign of disinformation designed to
conceal the date and location of the
main Allied invasion of France The
Landing was planned to take place at
Normandy but after a series of fake
operations and false information leaks
by agents like Popov Hitler became
convinced the Allies would come straight
over the English Channel from Dover and
attempt to land in Calais Operation
Fortitude was a huge success leaving the
German forces suitably scattered when
the D-Day Landings took place on the 6th
of June 1944.
it proved to be a turning point in the
war with victory in Europe coming less
than a year later amongst a celebration
however for Popoff there was also
personal sadness in the weeks prior to
the Normandy invasion his great friend
Johnny yepsen was exposed as a double
agent it turned out popoff's old friend
had been working against the Nazis all
along when yebson's deception was
discovered he was arrested by the
gestapo and tortured for information
remarkably he didn't break even under
interrogation and he never released the
names of his accomplices including Popov
in the end the Epson was taken to a
concentration camp and tragically
he was never seen again after the war
Popoff was sent to Paris to try and
establish a British intelligence Network
whilst he was there the so-called Iron
Curtain fell across Europe and
Yugoslavia became a communist country
this strictly no fun ideology was never
going to appeal to someone who used to
charge the cost of his silk shirts to
his spymaster employers so Popoff stayed
in the west he got married had some
children got divorced got married to a
second wife he was almost 30 years
younger than him had some more children
and lived in the Hills behind cons in
the south of France textbooks still for
a retired secret agent not that anybody
actually knew about his former life by
the way he didn't reveal his past to
anyone not even friends or family
but in 1972 Sir John masterman who'd
been responsible for controlling the
Allies double agents during the war
wrote all about it in a book called the
double cross system as one of the Allies
star agents popov's name naturally
featured quite a bit and with the cat
well and truly out of the bag Popoff
himself followed suit and in 1974
released his own book entitled spy
counter spy which was a somewhat
embellished autobiography making the
most of his bondian lifestyle Popov
lived another seven years continuing his
heavy smoking and hard drinking ways
just as James Bond the character he
inspired and Ian Fleming the author who
created him had also both done
he died age 69 in 1981. same year that
for your eyes only the 12th official
Bond movie was released by this point
the most famous spy in screen history
had been pulling in the crowds for
almost two decades and nobody did it
better
although the man on whom he is based may
be much less well known his place in
history is also secure after he
dedicated five years of his life to
fighting the Nazis with bravery and
Ingenuity and what a life it was pop-off
traveled the world dated numerous
beautiful women eight at the finest
restaurants and gambled with Millions he
risked his life for the greater good and
had a bloody good time whilst doing it
all in all for a man codenamed tricycle
it was quite a ride
thanks for watching